strap yourselves in and make sure to
bring your epi pens because we have
episode two of night fliers so prepare
to get probed picking up where episode
one left off Carl extinguishes krispy
Murphy and finds out he's still alive as
fail ventures further into the ship lomi
nearly having gotten herself trapped and
the computer goes back to her cabin and
experiences horrific flashbacks they
seem to be of someone tied to a chair
with terrible lacerations all over his
body
it shows lomi in the past brutally
torturing this man beating him with a
hammer it also appears to take place on
earth or at least some planet with
sunlight coming through
she's interrupted by fail who is able to
see this memory since she knows the ship
he wants her help to get to the domes
she says he can use the maglev tunnels
to get there maglev a reference to the
magnetic levitation system used by
trains in which the Train levitates off
the ground to get from point A to point
B fail blackmails her if she tells
anyone she saw him he'll then tell them
about her dark secret Murphy gets some
much-needed rest in the medbay while
Agatha and Carl tell captain Aris his
priority should be to find which
crewmember let Phil out but the captain
isn't having it and still thinks there
was a massive threat and here we see
Agatha taking the maglev in search of
thea before she finds this man bleeding
from his orifices proclaiming he's in my
head now I'm not exactly against they'll
hear all of his actions so far have been
in self-defense he's not 100% evil so
I'm interested to see where this goes
in her room we catch lonely tinkering
with her neural port she's obviously
trying to hide something as we can tell
when Mel arrives she hides a device
under her bed lomi opens up about what
happened the other day something in the
computer wanted her dead Mel finds the
blood seeping from low Me's arm and it
appears that loli may have been trying
to remove her neural port but before she
can explain she once again witnesses
this man tied up laughing at her now I
think it's safe to say this isn't fail
he's already got what he wants from her
leading me to believe another l1 is on
board the security team finds Agatha and
the search for thell begins in the dome
Carlin Agatha find him first and seemed
to be making some progress before the
security team scares him off making fail
believe this was all a setup
but as Carl goes off he's walked in the
head by sucuk all
he questions the captain saying that
with three men down and them being only
a colony ship perhaps they should turn
back
eros says it's out of the question and
judging by the look on Auggie's face he
isn't too happy with the decision
perhaps this is sowing the seeds for a
mutiny later on bonus points if he
spotted what appears to be Jupiter in
the background sucuk and Oberon lead the
security team into the dome and split up
when sucuk spots fail and blasts them
with his energy gun seeing his moment to
rid the night flyer of the l1 for good
he takes out his knife before he stopped
by Dobrin it isn't fail rather one of
his men fails mind-control powers are
just too much they'll then takes the
opportunity to pick up one of the guns
the men dropped Karl confronts Eris once
again claiming Thales innocence but the
captain isn't having it so Karl storms
off claiming he'll proof they'll did
nothing wrong sucuk and Oberon visit one
of the lab techs in search of something
robotic to stop Thales something he
can't control they want a retrofit one
of these spiders with lasers under the
dome fail is visited by crazy B lady
over here but she seems unfazed even
though fail has a gun pointed at her she
tells him he has the colony in an uproar
but in this scene it has a double
meaning is she referring to the ship or
the colony of bees she can seemingly
control around her also worth noting is
that the sound around them make it so
that they'll can't read her mind
nonetheless he takes her as his prisoner
carl has another sweet moment with his
dead daughter who is seemingly possessed
by something but at least he knows she's
not real I think it's safe to assume
it's not failed doing this he then
visits Rouen expressing his concerns
Eris might abort the mission they have
to launch the white rabbit early a probe
which I'm assuming will make contact
with the Vulcan Carl and Agatha take a
burned Murphy out of the med bay for
their plan as lomi is caught by Oggy
trying to access the ship's memory
storage
perhaps Murphy's memory will exonerate
fail Oggy helps them out but something
tells me he's not the most trustworthy
person
Rowan and Mel make the proper
adjustments to the white rabbit the
white rabbit symbolic of Alice in
Wonderland like how Alice followed the
white rabbit into the unknown be lady
introduces herself as Tessa for someone
who is the prisoner of an l1 she
actually seems like the one who's in
control
trol here probing failed to learn more
about him also interesting is the name
teshia which means harvester keep that
in the back of your mind for now Carl
and Agatha Murphy up to the memory
machine and we learned Oggy actually set
up a mirror program so he could also see
what's going on we learned the truth
that it was fail who lit him on fire but
since there may be someone else on board
who we know can manipulate Minds there
is still the possibility it wasn't fail
our memories often play tricks on us and
if Murphy were being manipulated by this
other force it's possible it made him
see thier light him on fire when it
actually wasn't Rowan and Mel launched
the probe before Mel pleads to Eris to
trust Carl but even more foreboding is
Aris telling her that the mission faces
a threat she doesn't understand a threat
beyond a rogue l1 the spider bot seems
to be malfunctioning and judging by the
red security camera over here it seems
as though something has infiltrated the
ship's system the same red camera scene
when captain Harris does a complete 180
and informs Carl he'll cover up fails
murder leading me to believe this isn't
the captain at all or at least he's been
compromised he even asked Auggie to
delete the footage he recorder which
shows the apparent truth of the murder
back in the mission lab the robotic
spider that's going to be used to kill
fail has its coding rewritten coding
written so fast it couldn't be done by a
human
the spider then proceeds to Massacre
Dobrin in the lab tech Carl and Agatha
visit failed to take him back to his
dome but the interesting thing about
this scene is that even though we see
Tessa she never speaks to anyone else
and no one acknowledges her presence
this is someone who's been held prisoner
and no one even asks if she's okay is
Tessie 'simply in Thales mind Mel
encourages lomi to get back into the
system to find out what's going on with
the probe while Eris investigates the
aftermath of the spider attack
it looks like sucuk made it for how long
we don't know but the spider is now
loose on the ship Carl has a call with
joy who seems to be undergoing some
therapy which removes all the bad
feelings associated with the loss of
their daughter another hint that
memories in this universe can be
manipulated or even deleted in the
corridor eros explains to Carl that
there's a force onboard trying to
jeopardize the mission
but he can't explain any further without
compromising the safety of everyone
onboard and Carl just ain't havin
eris ventures back into the mission lab
and finds the spider which he's easily
able to override with a voice command he
talks to the security camera saying this
time you've gone too far as the episode
ends now I'm inclined to believe that
whatever thing is controlling and
manipulating the ship is Eris's mother
who has somehow been turned into an AI
after all Eris even says that his mother
really never cared about the colony she
cared more about being a legend living
on forever it's not just coincidence
that this is the first episode in which
Eris's mother has been brought up
multiple times I also don't think this
is the last time we'll see Tessa who
seems to have somewhat supernatural
powers in line with fails I'm interested
to see where that goes I hope you
enjoyed watching this breakdown I'm
planning to do more of the series as it
goes on so make sure to LIKE share and
subscribe to stay up-to-date with
everything night fliers and remember
daddy loves you very much